Good morning to
Good Morning.
Good morning, sir.
Good morning, sir. Good morning. Good morning, God.
Morning, sir. Morning,
uh, Dr.
Sunil? Yes. I, yes.
Will you share the screen or shall I share?
I'll share, sir.
Yeah, so
We can, we can start from here, sir.
Yeah. Yeah. So whenever you say I'll,
We can start, sir. I
guess already. Two, three minutes done.
Okay. Um,
Good morning. All.
Uh, so, so far, um,
we explained about, uh, uh, the
progress in terms of, uh, um, impro, uh, know,
increasing the, uh, architecture, um, of
it forward neural network and training such network.
We started with, um, a single layer perceptron,
which can deal with, uh, linearly separable classes.
Then we added, uh, um, one more perceptron layer,
which can deal with linearly inseparable problems,
but there are convex in nature.
Then we added on more layer,
which results in multi-layer perception.
Mm. With that multi-layer perception, any type of, uh,
pattern machine learning task
or patternation task can be handed.
Uh, however, we ended up with that structure, we ended up
with hard learning problem, so that's
where propagation learning algorithm was proposed.
And so explained in detail about know how to train
apro learning algorithm and, uh, different ways,
and also how to, uh, how it ensures convergence,
different methods for, you know, training the
multi-layer perception, all those things he explained.
See, after this, people started thinking, uh,
can we, um, increase the complexity of the network,
um, such that we can, we,
we may be able to do, uh,
more complex pattern recognition tasks compared to
what is being currently done by multi-layer perceptron.
Um, essentially from three layer perceptron,
can you increase it to multiple more, many more layers?
And also, can I have more neurons in each layer compared to
what is being visualized currently in the
multi-layer perceptron?
And that thought led to, uh, the proposal
of many new, uh, architectures in the neural network theory,
which were termed as advanced concept in, um,
neural networks, which were later converted into,
uh, this, the later standard terminology
that became deep networks.
And later, they're,
they're all called as deep learning field.
That all comes under the deep learning car out
and made a separate field called deep learning.
Now, we will see from this class onwards
how the transition was made from the conventional
or artificial networks to deep networks.
So that is what, uh, uh,
the journey will start into the deep learning area.
Next slide. De C, um,
I, I might have mentioned in one of the earlier classes,
but just for no information, um,
this bpro once the bap propag, see,
the first breakthrough in the artificial network theory was
a coming up with a perception model, neuron model
of perceptron, uh, which has a learning capability
that is treated as the first breakthrough
in the neur networks field.
And again, when the feed
for new network architecture was proposed,
they ended up in the hard learning challenge.
And, uh, the second breakthrough came in the neur networks
field in terms of the provocation learning algorithm.
After that, even though people visualize it
as advanced neural network com, neural networks as a, um,
a concept for, um, increase to deal
with increased complex pattern recognition tasks,
but they were unable to demonstrate practically, uh,
ability to train such big networks
accordingly, there was no improved performance achieved.
So as a result of that, no,
the interest in the neural network field went
down late nineties.
Uh, even the shalon neural networks also, even though
that is early nineties, everything people are talking about,
neuro, neuro systems, neurons, neural network systems,
fuzzy systems, neuro fuzzy systems like that,
there are a lot of hype there at that point of time,
in spite of all of that, the performance
of any system based on neuro
or neuro for Z, all those things,
or even, uh, in some cases only comparable
to the alternative models or even inferior in many tasks.
So that's where no people felt to,
no, no, no, this will not work.
And they left the field.
Few groups, only few groups, which were very proponents
of this neural network, uh,
field from the beginning means we were there with the thicks
and thins of the neural network field network.
From the initial developments, they continued to work,
uh, in the neural network.
Now exploring why we are not able
to train in a deep network.
Okay, these are, for example, one
of the famous thing is such a free hint, uh, group, uh,
from city of Toronto.
They continue to work, uh, uh, in the new network area,
uh, exploring the possibility of declining deep network.
Similarly, Ben's group, uh, again, in Canada, university
of, I don't know, Magill
or something, some university, they're also working,
and a few more groups.
They were silently working on how to make
or train how to train these networks.
So that is the late nineties, two, early 2000,
nearly 15 years.
They were silently working on how do we come up
with a method for, how do we demonstrate
that it is indeed possible to train in a deep network, and
accordingly it should show significantly better performance.
Um, now towards the turn of the century,
um, what happened is, um, um,
uh, they,
there are two more developments happened in
the technology field.
One is because more
and more applications were digitized in many
of the practical tasks, the digital data amount
of digital data available became so big that now,
now there is no data scarcity
for training the deep networks.
And the second thing is, uh, so of the century,
we also got this GPUs, which have much more powerful
computing abilities compared to CPUs.
So that with the help of that, I can find this,
I can process this large data
and these two additional
features being made available in the early 2000.
And the continued exploration community was looking into
how do I refine the bap propagation algorithm,
b propagation process to train the deeper networks.
So, um, for example, the repayment, the did,
they did not know, remove the bap propagation algorithm.
They studied when I'm using abrupt provision algorithm
to train the deeper network where I am going wrong.
And at that point, can I initiate something?
One of the things they did was in a conventional,
multi-layered perception, when we are training the network,
we begin with the random initialization of weights.
Okay? Uh, then they thought,
can we do a clever initialization of weights?
Means instead of random, can we have a mechanism
to initialize the weights of the network, such
that they're already, they already know something about the
task that I'm doing means they know more about the data
that I'm going to use it for timing.
That is that clever initialization of the, uh,
methods they explore.
And, uh, also they explored about, you know, um,
the output function, uh, which we're using, uh, uh,
logistic function, uh, sigmoidal, uh, function.
Um, can I modify
or use alternative output function
to help better propagation of the error?
These were the two important, um,
modification they did to the algorithm.
So with that, all these things increase the data
availability and computing power and, um, modification
or refinements to the propagation process algorithm.
There is no change process, uh, uh,
and with the high increase in computing time, we are able
to, um, uh, uh,
reduce the experimentation time
and with all came in hand in hand.
So that is how the transition started towards
the deeper networks.
Next slide, sir.
This is what I have told.
One is, uh, at the turn of the century,
there are several advances, again, brought back popularity
to the neural networks.
Not all of these are no algorithm centric.
It's not that, no, the random, they, uh, came up
with a breakthrough new algorithm
for training the deeper networks, what made, uh,
two important additional developments
or increased data availability
and increase computational power
and, uh, changes to basic web propagation process,
which in terms of clever methods for initializing
and also, you know, changing the output function,
all those things, so increase the data computational power
and reduce the testing time, we all contributed
to coming up with a method for, uh, um, uh,
improving the, uh, now uhtraining process
for the deep networks.
Next slide. Now,
essentially after that, uh, uh, they were able
to demonstrate that it's, we'll see that in the later part
of the, they were unable.
They were able to demonstrate that with all
that interventions we were able to try in a deeper network,
um, and show the performances significantly better compared
to simple multi-layer perceptance.
Then after that, no, uh, till today, this is this,
they mastered in 2006.
From 2006 to now about two decades, we are completing by,
uh, another one month or so in two decades.
There's a lot of improvements
that have happened in the deep learning area.
So, and they were indeed able to now
successfully demonstrate that these deep networks
can represent increasingly complex functions
within the input and output data.
Accordingly, we can use it
for doing complex pattern recognition tasks
or complex machine learning tasks.
We want to see, okay, we'll see what are those
complex pattern regression tasks.
Um, they can be broadly classified
into three categories.
One is, um,
the complex pattern recognition task done by humans,
but, uh, because of the, uh, you know,
the cognitive system we are enrolled with and day in
and day out exposure to this task, over time,
these tasks become effortless for humans.
For example, um, visual observation of a scene
by our visual sensory mechanism.
It's an effortless job for that.
Suppose in that location, if I put a video camera
and ask to do, develop a no,
what we call actionable intelligence from the visual scene,
uh, it'll not be, uh, possible like humans.
Similarly, humans can recognize speech even in a very noisy
environment, and still that's a challenge for, um,
machines during the era of neural networks.
But for humans, it is very easy, uh, generating speech,
visual scene observation,
and deriving actionable intelligence
or, um, uh, producing speech or recognizing the speech.
All those things are, uh, one set
of pattern recognition tasks.
Uh, our machine learning tasks, which are easy
and effortless for humans,
but they, they proved to be very hard task
or complex task for shallow neural networks,
deep neural networks.
They were able to demonstrate that, uh,
they can tackle these complex ization tasks, uh,
like humans, very human-like task automation.
They can do, they can now analyze the scenes.
They can recognize speech, generate speech
and their performances, like they tutor the performance
of human level performance.
That is one class of complex petion task.
Next, increase the, uh, complexity complex, uh,
patternation tasks are, uh, creative content generation.
See, uh, humans have enrolled ability for creative
content generation, but they require relatively more time
or more involvement compared to
the patronization task that I described earlier.
For example, I want to generate a figure,
or I want to generate a poem, okay?
Um, or I want to write a piece of note
or speech that's a creative content generation, okay?
That creative content generation, uh,
is, um, also a, a complex pattern technician task,
but requires literally more time compared to these tasks.
What I do, visual scene analysis, uh,
auditory scene analysis, all those things, okay?
And, uh, people know when we were doing
before in the earlier era of Shalon Neur networks,
the first level of task itself we were not able to solve.
That's why we were not even thinking about this creative
content generation task.
But now, uh, since they solved this problem first level,
in the second level of complexity problems, now, uh,
deep learning models are able to create new content,
create new content.
For example, uh, best example, we have chat, g, pt
or perplexity or any of these tools,
they can generate new content, okay?
Um, no, with growing success, we are able to use them.
Uh, no, it, it, I will say them as a, uh, first cut
draft, easily available for us within a fraction of, uh,
hour for us to edit
and make a quick finalize contact for us.
Okay? That is the creative content generation.
The next one is, the third one is, um, now there are tasks
where for humans, it,
it is becoming highly impossible.
For example, the field of data science
and AI itself, when I'm talking about data science,
I'm talking about billions
of data points being collected on a regular basis
for a particular pattern recognition
or machine learning task.
In that scenario, you can't even load those data points
to your, uh, computer terminal
and start analyzing
what you are doing earlier using spreadsheet, if
that is the case, how to deal with such large heaps of data.
Now, deep learning models are able to do that.
They do that and generate you actionable intelligence
and throw this out in the form of visual,
visual representation for you, okay?
Then you see, know, uh, depending on, um,
the, uh, the visualization patterns that generate, you know,
the base or reference, uh, visualization patterns
and the new pattern that is being thrown out
by processing the data, by automatically,
by the deep learning model,
if there is a no change in the pattern,
and from your domain knowledge
or expertise, you can take a call on what to be done for
that particular, okay?
So that is what the humanly impossible tasks also,
now they started doing.
It is not that, no, this is not, uh, intellectually it is,
even though it is not challenging, but, uh,
because of the volume of data, it is not possible, uh, to
deal with such data in a manual manner.
That's where I say humanly impossible task,
and that also the deep learning models are able to, so
that is how these are the capabilities now we are enjoying
in as a field of deep learning.
And this all be became because, became reality
because of the ability to train the deep networks.
And, uh, this is what they dream dreamt in the late,
late nineties when the proposal is advanced
neural network models, which we later called
as deep learning or deep networks.
People visualize it like that.
We should be able to do all these tasks,
but they struggled, uh, to train the network.
That's where the whole interest went down. Next slide.
Uh, Sunil, this is
what I told, uh, no, next slide.
Now then, what was that challenge?
To train a deep learning model
or deep network there, there's a well-known, very famous
problem that was associated
with the deep learning model training
that is called vanishing or exploding gradient problem.
Okay? This was the main hidden obstacle, uh,
for enabling or training the deep learning models.
And that is what knowing this session, I think, uh,
Sunni sir will explain in detail,
but I'll just give the introduction for that.
What happens is, uh, if you recall
what we discussed earlier in the multi-layer perception,
there are three perception layers, uh, just for imagination.
Suppose there is an input layer after that.
There is a first layer, first perception layer.
Yeah, I call it as a firsted layer, which let me call it as,
um, hidden layer one
and the next hidden layer, central layer,
I call it hidden layer two,
and the next hidden layer is hidden layer three, uh,
not hidden layer three, it is output layers.
Yeah, output layer one, two, yeah, output layer. Okay?
So there are totally four layers
of the network without multi-layer three perceptions are
there from the input layer.
Next hidden layer one, hidden layer two, and output layer.
All these three are perception layers.
Now, what happens, uh, the, we, we, we,
we overcame the problem of, uh,
training multiplayer perception, hard learning problem
using web propagation learning where, uh, instead of, uh,
um, the sigmoidal function, uh, sorry,
hard limiting function, we came up with sigmoidal functions,
which had non-zero, um, differentiation, um,
derivative or gradient.
As a result of that, I can pass the error in the output
layer two hidden layer one output,
and in layer two output, once I have that error, I can use
for adjusting the weights of the, um, links connected to
that hidden layer 1 90 10, layer two.
But when the increase of the network, what happened,
you see, I'm passing the error as a process of derivative.
We all know from our cal class
that when I take a derivative, the value decreases, okay?
Gradually, if you take, uh, in, in, in, um, uh,
propagation learning algorithm, we are going through, uh,
what we call chain rule, uh, first derivative,
second derivative, third derivative, derivative, derivative.
That's happening. So as, as we increase the derivative,
as you are moving towards the hidden layers in the input
layer towards the input layer,
the the gradient value reduces
whatever the computer error reduces when it reduces.
So one, one thing we know, the common way
of perception learning is, uh,
the target output minus the actual output,
that error is there.
If that error is zero, we stop the training.
Now, what is happening is the assumption is we have learned
the information, but now in the case, what is happening is
because of this decrease in the error, uh,
because of the partial derivative, uh, we are taking
as you move, um, as you move towards, uh,
hidden layers which are closer towards the input layer,
the gradients become so small,
we say the gradients get vanished, okay?
Or if you vanish your gradients, you further start deriving,
it becomes a random value,
and it may explode also some random values.
So both have no meaning from
training point of view, learning point of view,
because now once they become a, take a very small barrier,
very large value, which has no relation
to the actual error generated between the target output
and the actual output, then use that value to adjust your,
if it is incredibly small,
then you don't adjust the weights.
That means to say the weights leading to
that particular layer are not being adjusted.
Alternatively, randomly it has become large by exploded.
Using that exploded value adjust the,
that also has no meaning.
So as a result of that, what was happening is no suppose,
um, there are, uh, um, if, if I
visualize a deep network as several modules, module one,
module two, module three, like module one,
10 layers are there.
Same say, uh, the several
of these modules are not being trained.
As a result of that, there a gap,
there is no way I can pass the information flow from the
input layer towards the output layer
because they're not trained.
So when they're not trained, the signal flow doesn't happen,
and then accordingly, they cannot do machine learning.
So now this exponential error signal, um,
the BA propagated error signal decreases exponentially
or increases exponentially increase exponentially is only
because of now computational complexity
and also limitation of the digital computation.
Okay? So that is what happens with the first,
uh, error inability to bap propagation.
So as a result of that, I'm not able to
bap propagate the errors to when the length
of the network be goes beyond 3, 2, 3, 4, like that, okay?
According, you know, there is a poor model learning
and, uh, so I think we might have also touched
upon how do we stop training The multi-layer perception
network is one way the error becomes minimum.
If the error is not becoming minimum
and it's flatten half, then we take,
that is also another criteria.
If the change in the error from the previous situation
to next situation is less than certain value,
then it cannot further, uh, learn anything, you stop it.
Now, poor convergence, it'll happen. Poor performance.
So premature converge, it is happening.
This unstable gradient behavior
resulted in not able to try in the network.
So this was the problem.
Just as a layman tell me if I say,
suppose if it has same six layers, hidden layer one
to hidden layer five in the hidden layer block,
one input layer is there one, uh,
six layer is the output layer.
Now, if I try to train such a, a six layer,
um, perception network, uh, from the output layer,
maybe hidden layer five weights,
maybe trying even layer four becomes poor hidden layer
3, 2, 1, we are not able to train.
Naturally, there is a gap. Signal flow cannot happen. Okay?
So because of this,
people are not knowing how to deal with that.
That is the problem they face
for nearly more than a decade on how
to train the deep networks.
Next slide. This is what I,
I told you this, um, deep,
deep neur network was unable
to back propagate useful gradient information termed
as it became exponentially small,
which is technically termed as managing gradient
or exponentially large exploding grad exploding gradient
will happen because our binary word length in a registered
lens, everything, no, uh, if you were,
you go on differentiating that decimal point
after explodes, then it becomes some random one.
So that is what, uh, so, uh,
as a result of this inability of the models with many layers
to learn a given pattern information
or prematurely converge to some poor solution.
Next slide. So then people started
analyzing, you know, how do I make this, um, uh,
deep network to climb?
The first thing they identify the root cause they identified
that is this gradient problem.
This is what is, it is becoming either vanishing gradient
or exploding gradient.
How do I preserve that gradient
to an appreciable value representing the output error, okay?
For that, of course, they tried many things.
Finally, the successful thing was, uh,
you replace sigmoidal output function
with a real output function, okay?
First, we replace a step output function,
which was there in the basic percept run with the, um, uh,
sigmoidal output function
because it has a non-zero, uh, differential value.
When I take F dash x where f physio sidal function
in non-zero output, uh, as a result of that, I'm able
to back propagate the errors to the,
but what happened was this non, if you recall,
I think SAR may show in one slide, the,
the differential value
of the sigal function also is non-zero,
only over a small range of, uh, input X values.
Beyond that, it becomes zero.
If it is zero, then again, you're not able to ate.
If the values are beyond that range,
they wanted an output function,
which has a differential appreciable differential value
gradient and very high value.
That is where one of the thing they came up
with the function.
If you see relo function, um, the slope is always one,
so naturally it'll not, uh, it'll overcome the effect
of the vanishing or exploding gradient.
That is where the first thing the replace it
is output function.
The second thing they did was, instead
of random initialization, is it possible to, uh,
um, adjust the weights of the neural network
before employing the bap propagation algorithm means
pre-train the weights, uh, with the reference to the
input data that is available, input output data
that is available, pre-trained means already have exposed
that data not through the bap propagation
by some other procedure such
that they already learned some information about the,
that particular, uh, data point,
and that is what, you know,
they explored different weight initialization mechanism
and these two, uh, enabled them to
overcome the problem of vanishing
or exploding gradient problem,
and they finally demonstrated that it is indeed possible
to train the, uh, deep network.
Next slide. Yeah, that's what, uh,
alternate weight initialization
and alternate activ activation.
That's where no, I initially, I told
we did not throw away the BA propagation learning algorithm.
We only found out what is going wrong
that is vanishing in the exporting gradient problem.
And then what is the solution for that?
One is alternate activation function
or output function, alternative
weight installation mechanism.
So the alternative weight installation mechanism they came
up with was unsupervised pre-training,
which is done in a layer wise training manner.
Okay? And uh,
then later the explored supervisor counterpart also, instead
of suppose I, I told no, I have a six layer network,
one input layer as a seven layer network.
We, among them six are perception layers.
Um, so now when I want to train the six layer,
I train each layer separately.
That is called layer wise separately in some other process,
and then command, just like no modular construction, we do,
you, you build that each module separately somewhere,
cast it and bring it and direct it here.
That is the way they follow layer wise training. Okay?
And then at that point, what happened, even
to some extent, uh, the vanishing
or exploiting Bulgarian problem is there to some extent,
but since these are already explored in a layer waste
training manner, they represent the input data information.
That's why they were able to overcome the, uh,
difficulty in training the model.
Okay? And the alternative activ function was they used a
rectifier rectified linear unit activation function instead
of that hyperbolic tangent or SIG model function.
Okay? I think rail are already shown somewhere.
It will explain again, so it's like a linear function,
easier to try and less likely to saturate,
but an nonlinear function
because the negative values we are forcing it to save.
Okay, next.
Next. Yeah, I think, uh, Sunil,
any, any, any, uh, other questions up to this point?
Any of you?
Any questions? Uh, no, sir.
It is clear. Yeah. Okay. Thank you.
Uh, I think now the SIR will explain about
the vanishing gradient problem.
Thank you.
Fine, sir. Thank you, sir. Okay,
so I'll continue from here that,
and first of all, try
to see the vanishing gradient problem in little more detail
and, uh, yeah,
Uh, just one question I have here, sir.
Uh, why is it, uh,
relu preferred over the tanish for vanishing gradient?
Sir, even though the relu can cause the dead neurons?
Hmm, uh,
I think sir will explain that.
Uh, essentially, um, we wake, um,
uh, maybe, um, if I have a slide, uh, Sunil,
uh, uh, the way, um, I showed, uh, uh, the differential
of the sigal function somewhere.
Yeah, I, I think we have shown it, sir,
Earlier we have shown it, Uh,
In the previous slide deck,
Uh, in the previous slide deck, it was yes, second,
Ah, that's slide This one, sir.
Yes. Okay,
Next.
Ah, CC suppose if I take sigal function, okay,
which we are using in conventional provisional learning,
either you can go with logistic function
or hyperbole logistic, the shape
of the function remains same in case of logistic function.
The function value output function value goes from zero
to one, whereas this is going from minus one to one,
but as x value increase,
that the X is the activation value
is coming out of the neuron.
FFX is the neuron output, okay?
If you see no, uh, as say for x, uh,
as it becomes slightly large, the the FFX value saturates,
that means to say, if I take that, uh, differential
of the F dash X in the next function,
the non-zero value is there only this bell shape,
reverse bell shape curve.
You have bell shape curve.
You have have, okay, beyond this, if you have X value,
then you cannot propagate that back
because that gradient has become zero.
You are, uh, so, and same thing that nature remains.
Same for, um, um, the other tangent, uh,
verbal function also that means to the range of operation
for the neural neuron output will be only a very small range
around x equal to zero around the origin.
But as I move towards the inner layer,
this x value may become larger, the exceed that limit,
and if then that derivative is zero,
I will not be able to pass on.
There may be some slide, uh, Sunil,
where you showed the rail output function ally,
I saw somewhere, Ah, somewhere.
See if you take this rail output function,
this is the nature of the output function.
Uh, it is linear from zero on positive value
and zero in the negative value.
Hello? Is it okay?
Yes, sir. Ah, so now suppose you take the,
because of this sudden cut zero BA below one, and
because this one, uh, beyond zero,
it qualifies the definition of an nonlinear function.
And whereas when I take the slope,
you see now you have a constant slope one, okay?
Any value X instead of Z is uh, x there any value of X
or Z, you take, you always have a constant value slope.
Slope will never become zero.
So then naturally the gradient effect will reduce, okay?
And I need an output function, which is non-linear,
otherwise I will not be able
to deal complex pet transmission.
That is how we move from, uh, uh, linear
to non-linear function
because the output function has to be, uh,
non-linear as per the basic functioning of the neuron to con
to conduct any patternation task.
This qualifies both non-linear as well
as the slope is more or constant. So
Yes, sir.
Thank you.
So you are muted, sir.
Certainly you're muted.
Yeah, sorry. So just wanted to add what sir was telling
that if at this point of time at this, uh, uh, point, uh,
in this, uh, uh, uh, where you said that it becomes, uh,
dead, okay, dead neuron, right?
Mm-hmm. Which is correct, because if you take the derivative
of zero here, uh, you will not get anything.
And that's where there are different forms of the,
which is proposed, okay?
Which slightly deviates completely as uh, zero
for the negative value,
and it goes a little, I mean, it takes some data to instead
of becoming completely zero on zero and
after, in the negative part, there are some different forms
of the re relu, which will learn later part of the time
like leaky relu, uh, or, um,
and a few more forms are there that takes care of that also,
that, uh, to, uh,
because at zero, I understand what you said,
that it becomes debt, right?
Was it the question? If it is, if I'm getting correct?
Yes, sir. That's, that was the question.
Yeah, fine, fine. Okay, thanks.
Okay, then I will,
Okay, So the plan is for the next, uh,
uh, another 45 minutes or so what we have,
but first we'll try to understand the vanishing gradient
problem by taking some a NN
and we'll have some four, five layers of the, uh,
neural network, I mean very simplest neural network, just
to show that how exactly the gradient vanishes
once you back propagate with this deep, deep, uh,
uh, deep neural network.
Um, so that is, uh, first thing we'll understand it, uh,
visually means we are going to irate, uh, reiterate our, uh,
forward propagation and back part propagation.
And then with that we'll understand this vanishing gradient.
And then once we'll understand this theoretically,
then we'll also switch on to the, uh, hands-on
where we'll see that, okay,
what is the value which is coming
and what are the, with the plots, we'll try
to understand the when, when the, uh, gradient vanishes,
then how it becomes, uh, the slope becomes zero,
and all those things we'll try to visualize so that our, uh,
clarity on this vanishing gradient problem will
be, uh, complete.
So that is, that is what is the plan for today,
and if time permits, we'll also go into the solutions
for this vanishing gradient problem.
Otherwise, we'll see that in the next class.
So, uh, vanishing gradient problem adds, uh,
already told during the back propagation gradients are
computed layer by layer
and uh, uh, in the,
from the output layer towards the input layer.
And for that, we use the chain rule and chain rule.
All of us has already seen that in the chain rule.
What we do, we have many gradients,
which we are doing the multiplications,
and if the multiple multiplicative factors
are less than one,
their product across many layers can shrink
exponentially towards zero.
Now, that is the vanishing gradient problem.
So it'll result as very small gradient for early layers.
And just because the early layers gradients are very small,
weights will hardly update.
And if the weights are not changing,
although you will go with the iteration by iteration
or epox to ep, you will not see much change
or any change in the loss reduction.
Now, this is the impact, what you will see from
the vanishing gradient problem.
That's why it is very important
to tackle the vanishing gradient problem.
Okay? And main culprits
for this vanishing gradient problems are like sigmoid,
which we have just explained that y it is because
after certain point on the X
or Z, which is on the x axis, your y be saturated.
So y becomes is always one or, uh, very close to one.
And for that one, if you calculate the slope,
because it is saturated like horizontal line, so the slope
of that becomes zero.
Okay? So this is one of the main culprits for that.
Poor initialization is another problem, which may lead
to the vanishing gradient problem as well
as the deep networks.
We'll see that that deep network itself can be sometimes the
region for the vanishing gradient problem, obviously.
So the solution for
that could be like convert the deep network
to the shallow network, but uh, yeah,
that may have another problem, right?
So all these things are some of the regions
of getting the vanishing gradient problem in your network.
So just to understand it in a little, uh, uh,
more in depth,
and what we have done is I've taken this
simplest deep neural network example
where I have four layers.
You can see that I have one input, okay?
Along with that, I have four layers, a one, a two, a three,
and a four, and all these four layers are hidden layers,
and fourth layers are uh, uh,
this fourth layer is also my output layer.
So whatever is the output coming from a four
is equal to my y hat.
That is my final output,
which is coming from this particular network.
Now, just to make it very simple
and show you a little mathematics part, also, uh,
I have kept only one neuron in each layer,
but now you can imagine, right?
If we are having these four layers,
you can keep two neurons, three neurons,
10 neurons, a hundred neurons.
Now whatever you want, right?
So you can design the neuro network as per,
as per your requirement.
But here, just for demo,
we have taken just one neuron in each
layer, but we have four layers.
That is one thing. Now, another thing is that in each
of these layer, we have the sig wide function
with which we have, uh, uh, uh, used just to show
that sigmoid, how
how does it Im impact on the gradient, okay?
So, uh, that's why the sigmoid layers are,
are being used in, in each of these hidden layers.
Uh, then the weights, again, the weight just for simplicity,
the weights between input first layer, first
and layer second hidden layer
and so on is initialized with 0.5, the single weight
that is 0.5.
So these are some, uh, initializations what we have done
and say that this is the network, what we are going
to start with.
So, uh, quickly understand how does the forward pass work.
That X one here, which is one, gets multiplied with bl
and it results the weighted sum, which I say as Zed one, say
that Zed one, okay?
And zed one. Then we pass it through the activation function
that is sigmoid in this particular case
result us in A one.
Okay? So from Zed one, we are getting a one,
but for that one we are passing it through the sigmoid.
You can see that this function sigma
represents here the sigmoid, and that is nothing
but one divided one plus E to the power minus Z.
This we already know. So whatever value will come from Zed
one, we'll pass it through this activation function.
Now, a one, uh, which is the output
for this particular neuron, will act as an input
for the next layer neuron,
and then A one gets multiplied with the weight,
gives us Z two,
and that we pass it through the sigmoid gives us the A two.
Okay? You can understand, right, the sequential flow
and the weighted surplus bias, uh, that is
what we are calculating in, in, in each of these neuron.
Now, there is no, uh, there is no bias here, but
although we could have added,
but just again, uh, just to make it very simple bias value,
also, I have, uh, taken at zero.
So there is no bias part here.
So likewise, what we are doing is we calculate at every
neuron the weighted value, weighted sum value,
that is called zedi,
and then we, uh, calculate it's uh, uh, activation value
that is called ai.
So that's why we have Jet one A one here, then jet two,
A two here, jet three, A three here,
and jet four, A four here,
and finally, whatever is the A four that gives us the output
as y hat, okay?
This is a simple forward propagation,
which we have been seeing.
I don't see any problem in this,
this flow of the forward pass.
Now, once we calculate the forward pass, then the next,
the next step is to calculate the loss, right?
So loss value, uh, we have to calculate
between the prediction and the target.
Now, say that target value is zero just for, for the case
because it is say that classification problem
and the class is zero, um,
or say that it is zero rather than, uh,
going into the class part.
Let's say that it is zero.
So, uh, why, why, uh, why?
Whatever we will get as a, as a prediction,
we will then calculate the loss.
And this loss is this loss is a square,
square, uh, error y hat minus y square.
You can see that, right? Only this term is extra, uh, just
because I want to do some calculations
later part of the time.
So when I will take the partial derivative of the loss,
what will happen, because it is y hat minus y square,
it'll become two into y hat minus y, isn't it?
Partial derivative of excess square is called
to two x, right?
So in the same way, partial derivative
of y hat minus YS square will be two into y hat minus Y,
and the two will come in the nominator
and divided by two will cancel out each other hands.
My equation, what I'll get from this one will be relatively
simple and that will help me to, to do the calculator.
That's why one by two is taken here.
Otherwise, uh, there is no intention
of taking this one by two.
So it is optional, we can remove it also.
So do not get confused that, okay,
last time when we took the loss function,
it was quite error, but what is this one by two?
So it is taken just for a convenience,
otherwise, uh, there is no significant of this, uh, right?
If you don't take this one also, then also it'll work.
So here, what we are doing is
because my y is equal to zero, y hat will be some value.
Now we are taking the uh, uh, the qui error
and it'll nothing be nothing
but, uh, y hat minus YY is equal two zero.
So it'll result in y hat and y hat is nothing but my A four.
So that is what is written over here. Okay?
So now with this, what we have done is we have done the
forward pass, and even we have calculated the loss.
Now we will go for the back propagation, okay?
And here, just all the values are being substituted
and shown that, okay, what will be the Z one,
the first layer, and what will be the corresponding A one?
Okay? So then what will be the Z two
and corresponding A two, find what will be the,
uh, sorry, here, A two.
What will be the Z three corresponding A three
and Z four corresponding a four.
Okay? So this is how it is.
And finally, what will be the loss?
Loss will be the A four
and a four value is coming as 0.5709.
And that is qui we have to take. So this is the loss.
Now, uh, if you see that, uh, if you see that
what is happening
and why the gradient,
when we will start calculating the back propagation,
why the vanishing gradient will come, just
to give you a little understanding that see at the A one,
A one is a sigmoid of Z one, okay?
The V, we are applying the sigmoid activation function on
the Z one part, and that value at the first layer is coming
as 0.6.
Now, this value itself is very small, okay?
It's, it's a small, but 0.6 is a, uh, value.
What we are getting here. Now, if you see in the A two,
okay, A two, uh, which is nothing
but the sigmoid of Z two, that means here sigmoid of Z two.
Once we'll get the weighted sum, we are going to pass it
through sigmoid, and that's
how we'll we'll end up with a two value.
Now, a two value, what we have got is 0.576.
So there is a slight change. You will see, okay, 0.6 to 0.5.
Now, if you go to the next layer, next layer, like a three,
the next neuron here, we have here A three.
This change will be almost negligible that 0.57,
what we have got as a a two
and a three, if you see it is 0.571.
Now see that, uh, this,
this is almost neg negligible change.
So I have written here saturating that my
values are not changing.
Now you can imagine that part like x value is being
increased, so the corresponding Y gets saturated, okay?
After that, your Y will not increase
and that is what you can see.
That is what is happening.
And if you go to the next layer, again,
you will see there is no change front 0.571 2.571.
Now what it'll result
because the values are being saturated, why it is happening,
because we have already calculated sig ide
on this particular value.
Further, we are calculating, and then again we are applying.
So sig ide in being sig wide,
sigmoid functions are in nested form, okay?
So that, uh, that is how it results, uh, like
that here at least.
Okay? So we'll see that in the back.
Now we will, when we do the back propagation,
this will result, uh, almost like zero slope.
This will result in the zero slope.
So because observation is values hardly change network,
enter sigmoids flat region.
So networks is entering net, uh, sig mite flat region.
And now how it is going to impact on our gradient, that is
what we are going to see next.
So now we have done with the forward pass, again,
we are going to see the back propagation.
Okay? So before we'll start the back propagation, first
of all, you should be knowing what is the partial derivative
of loss with respect to sig mite, okay?
So sig I derivative is like this.
So if you take the sigmoid of z, Z is a weight, some value,
so sig mite of your value Z, then it'll be that sigmoid
of Z into one minus sigmoid of Z.
Now, this is what is the value you will get from the sig
mite derivative, okay?
So one good part is it is just in the form
of the sigmoid itself, z value, any way value we are having.
So if you can substitute that value, we will get that.
But one thing, what you can observe here is that
because multiple times we are going
to calculate the sigmoid, uh, gradient,
and we are going to multiply the sigmoid gradient
with the sigmoid gradient.
What will happen sigmoid will anyway give you the value
between zero and one,
and this, this quantity is going to be very small.
Again, if you put multiply it with another sigmoid,
the value will be even a smaller, even a smaller.
And that is what I'm going to show you next.
Let us see this. So from forward pass, a one, a two,
A three and a four, we have got the, uh, at each,
each neuron, these are the outputs
and sig ide derivatives at, uh, if you will calculate at uh,
uh, what is that, uh, Z one, it'll be 0.2.
So you can easily calculate sig ide derivative
by substituting the Z value in the equation.
And that is how it is coming as 0.2 3 5 0, 0 0.2
4, 4, 2, 2, 4, 4, 8, 2, 4, 5, 0 at each of these layers.
Fine. That is okay.
Now let us start with our back propagation.
Well, well, we know that when we start our back propagation,
we first of all see that
where is the output layers output At the output layer,
we had a neuron called a four A four, and the A four
and y hat both are same.
So what we do, we calculate the partial DER of loss
with respect to this y hat,
or we can say that partial derivative of loss with respect
to this a four because this is the point from where I have,
uh, calculated my loss value.
So loss directly depends on yhat.
So partial derivative of loss function with respect to yhat,
that is what, uh, we are, we are calculating now.
So y hat and a four are both are same.
So what I've done here is y values anyway is zero.
So y hat is a four,
and with respect to a four, this is how it'll come.
So now once you will, uh, take this two, this site two,
two will get canceled, and then you will, uh, get this value
as 0.5 7, 0 9 I guess, okay?
So that is one thing.
Now, um, we have calculated this first, first,
uh, gradient, okay?
Now what we have to do is if you go back into this network
now, partial bit of loss with respect to a four,
we have calculated now a four depends on the sigmoid of
set four, because a four value we have got
from sigmoid, isn't it?
So then what we have to do is we have to calculate parts
because we need to change these parameters, W four, W three,
W2, and W one.
These are the four parameters inside my network.
We have to update that one
before, we'll go for the next forward pass.
All these weights we want to update in order
to reduce my loss, okay?
So that's the intention. But, uh, how do we, uh, how did,
how do we arrive at W four?
We start with a four. Now a four we got from Z four.
And in order to calculate the Z four, we utilize this W
four into a three.
That is how we did, right? So
that's why we are going into the backward
with the help of chain tool.
And if you see that for that one,
the chain tool will be like that.
My loss depends on a four,
and a four is calculated using the sigmoid of Z four.
So here we are calculating the partial derivative
of sigmoid, okay?
And then here we have jet four, then we calculate partial
jet four with respect to A three, okay?
With respect to, so W three
and that results, uh, sorry, that W four
that results in a three.
You get this right here
because a three into W four is equal to Z four,
A three into W four is equal two Z four.
So if you take the partial derivative with respect
to W four, you will end up with a three.
Okay? That is what it is written here.
That is what it's written here. Okay?
Now we have 1, 2, 3 gradients value here.
So we just have to substitute these values, fine.
And if you'll substitute these values, you will end up
with the gradient as C.
All these values are less than one
and they're being multiplied with each other.
So at the output layer, the first, first, uh, uh,
output layer and uh, uh, the head layer, just
before the head layer, the gradient, what we are getting
is 0.0797.
Now, this value itself is very small right now.
So what you will do is with this gradient, you will go
and try change this W four value, which is nothing,
but W four is equal to W four minus parts.
Uh, what is that, uh, learning rate into
this gradient, okay?
Learning rate into this gradient.
So you see that already the W four will change very small.
If it'll change, it'll change with very small quantity.
But this is the situation at the layer four,
the last, last hidden layer.
Now we have to go down in the network up
to the first layer, right?
So now, we'll, what we'll do next effort will be
to update this parameter, W three.
Okay? So in order to update the W three first we have
to calculate partial derivative loss
with respect to W three.
And for that one, the chain rule will be this
partial derivative loss.
With respect to W three will be, first of all,
we'll start with the A four.
This is output layer A four, depends on my Z four.
So sig mite derivative Z four.
And then that depends on the, uh, my
W four weight, because now here we are calculating the
partial derivative of, uh, uh, Z four
with respect to a three.
So if you see here in this particular network, just
to not get, so with respect to a three,
when we'll calculate, we'll end up with W four.
Okay? Because A three becomes, uh, uh, constant.
So W four is the, uh, uh, only quantity, which is left with,
and hence, you are left with the W four.
That's why it is written here.
W four last time we calculated with respect to W four,
and hence we left with a three.
Once you do with respect to a three, you,
you'll left with W four.
And that is what is the trend here, okay?
Now, w uh, our intention is to go up to the W three.
So w once you, you once you are here, once you're here,
then next is the sig wide of W three.
Here again, we have the sig wide value of the W three.
So you have to calculate the partial derivative of sigmoid.
Once again, that is what it is.
Sigmoid dash, which is representing, uh, partial derivative
of sigmoid, having said three inside the function,
and then you can end up with the partial derivative
of W three, which is nothing but eight.
Now, see, these are all the quantity which we have
to multiply, and once you substitute all these value,
you end up with say that 0.03.
So last time it was 0.07. Now it has already reduced to 0.0.
Uh, three,
I don't know whether its values are corrected or not.
Just see that the calculations, uh,
just, just see that one, okay?
But you have to understand that we are,
we are now here multiplying a lot of, uh, uh, uh, gradients.
So obviously the value, what we are going
to get will be very small.
Okay? That is what I want to project here.
The calculations, uh, just, just, uh, see that by yourself.
One second. So then what happens?
Uh, this is about the, about this layer where we were trying
to calculate the gradient with respect to W three.
Now, next, we'll calculate the gradient with respect to W2,
and one more time we have to W one.
So now you see that with respect to W2, when we'll do,
we will have two more gradients here added.
Okay? Two more gradients here added.
So, uh, till, till this, uh,
A two means W three we have already done.
Now these two will be added.
First of all, we'll calculate the sigmoid derivative
with respect to Z two, and then we'll have a one, okay?
And this value will further reduce.
Say that by some quantity.
Now we have 0.01,
and next you have to calculate with respect to W one.
Now see that how many multiplicative factors we have,
how many gradients we are multiplying here,
and we end up with another smaller value with 0.006.
Say that. So if these values are correct,
although you can check by yourself, then if you see that,
if it's when, where we started from the output layer,
which was the fourth hidden layer,
and we have come all the way up to the first hidden layer,
uh, and, uh, in input layer.
So the gradient, which was 0.0797 is reduced
to 0.00645.
And this quantity, if you'll see it,
is almost 30 times smaller than the gradient,
which we have calculated at the output layer, right?
So earlier layers receives almost no gradient means this
value is so small that if you will start
substituting this gradient to four weight update of W one,
there will be hardly any update in the W one.
Okay? So this, this, this, this is shrinking,
this shrinking like anything.
And you can see that at the first layer, the gradient,
what you're receiving is very small.
Now, if it is very small, then what will happen?
This update rule what you have, uh, uh, earlier we had, uh,
uh, already, uh, seen this update rule where each
weight here we are going to update by w equal
to W minus learning rate into that gradient.
So supposedly W one.
Now this quantity is almost like a zero, almost like a zero.
So if this is zero, then this whole term will be zero.
And this WI will not change this. WI will not change.
Maybe for W four, you might see some change.
W three also W2 also.
And I mean, I don't say this is completely zero
because it's still, it is 0.00645,
but you have to understand the logic.
What I'm trying to say that this quantity have
becomes now very small.
And hence it is almost like negligible, almost like zero,
sorry, almost like, uh, zero.
So this whole term becomes zero
and your weight will not update.
Now, suppose your weight doesn't update in the early layers,
your weight doesn't update.
Then what will happen, I'll say that next time you have,
when you feed the same input
or say that different input,
this particular weight is not changing, say
that this particular weight is not changing.
You may see some change here and here, but
because early layer weights are not changing
for the new input or the same input, the kind
of representation which you are doing in the next layer
and next layer, that is not changing, okay?
So till this layer say that there was no change, okay?
So then having some change here will not impact much in
your overall loss.
Okay? So that is, that is the problem
which we will end up with.
So this is called this, this whole process.
With this whole process, what we are trying to project is
because the sigmoid was the activation function in between
and sigmoid has that, uh, uh, uh, any anyway,
sigmoid has the, uh, that, uh, saturation, uh, uh,
for the greater value of effects.
And once you calculate the partial derivative for that one,
multiplying multiple partial derivative for the sigma here,
it'll result in the smaller and, uh, further smaller
and very small values.
And hence, the weights will not update,
waste will not update.
Then what will happen, training will not improve,
and hence your loss will not reduce.
So these are all the consequences
of having the vanishing radiant problem, right?
So gradients are being vanished slowly once you go down in
the network at the time of the back population, right?
This is the point which we were, uh, just trying to project.
So this I have explained,
and similarly, you can see that the update size,
that in the first layer, the fourth layer,
the update might be little bit,
but in the third layer, it is already half second layer,
it's almost half of that.
In the first layer, it is almost negligible as compared
to the update, what it is happening in the fourth layer.
So first layer, second layer rates are changing very
slightly, and hence the, the, that, that, that impact of,
uh, uh, yet, uh, means no learning.
You will be able to see in the network. Okay?
So this was the, this was the, some,
some part which we wanted to explain.
Now we'll switch to the demo part, but
before that, if you have any query, you can ask me so
that then we can switch to the demo part for the same thing.
Uh, Rosa, I have a question, sir.
Sir, uh, since the, uh,
since we have this vanishing gradient mm-hmm.
Why can't we have a one by sigmoid function as some kind
of weight or bias to compensate for this?
Uh, I, I did not get, can you repeat?
Suppose we have a sigmoid function in each layer
'cause of sigmoid function.
We are getting this, uh, vanishing gradient problem, right?
Correct. So to compensate this, can we have one
by sigmoid function as weight or bias?
Okay. Okay. Uh, so you, and,
and bias, bias also, you are saying weight and bias,
Either weight or bias, Either weight or bias.
How will it help? I did not get that.
So here we have the gradients are getting, uh,
reduced rate, correct.
But, uh, when we keep on adding that bias,
whatever is reducing, can be compensated with
Oh, got it, got it, got it.
Okay. So yeah, the, I mean, you can,
I have not shown here the bias value and if you will add,
and, but the point is that bias value also,
see here the network is so small that you can visualize
that, okay, if I would have added some bias value here,
which would've compensated that, what is the, uh, leading
to the smaller value that you can visualize
and you can add also,
but the in reality, suppose you add bias value also,
and the network is so deep.
I mean, uh, putting the exact bias value also,
how will you do manually?
This is not a manual process. Okay?
Now, the, uh, like algorithm itself has to identify
that the bias is also a parameter like weights, okay?
Mm-hmm. So you can't be changing it very significantly.
The bias value, suppose this time it is 0.5,
next time you will make five just
because compensate the other things.
But how will you take that call? So that is the problem.
So bias has also taken, uh, considered as another parameter.
That means that it'll also change in the same way
how the other weights will be changing.
So then in that case, it'll be very difficult
to significantly change the bias
to compensate the other problems,
which is happening from the balancing radio.
That is the issue. Okay? Yeah.
So manually you can say that that is correct,
but for these, uh, once you'll actually implement
for deep network, that is, I mean, uh, that, that's, again,
you end up with this update rule
and update rule doesn't allow you
to change it very significantly for one parameter.
Yeah.
Yes. Okay. Rish? Yes, sir.
Circle, can learning rate help to reduce this problem, sir?
We can take big learning rate and
Correct, correct.
So, uh, actually we have seen
that in the earlier case when I was explaining the back
propagation where the gradients were very high, okay,
now the gradients are coming very slow,
but you remember was first time when we, uh,
learned the back propagation gradients very high,
we purposefully fully chosen learning it very small.
Similarly, in this case, when the is very small,
we could have chosen learning rate very high.
I mean, see that is a hyper parameter.
And definitely once you, uh, see, train the network
and you see that mine, uh, loss has almost, uh,
saturated is not decreasing anymore,
that time you can do some hyper parameter tuning.
But that will, that you will understand once obviously once
you'll see that there is a vanishing gradient problem
and changing the learning rate, taking a little bigger side,
these are all the solutions for the learning rate.
Obviously you can do that,
but for that one at least you have
to do one run, one dry run.
See that, okay, what is the impact with,
is there any managing grad problem or not?
And then only you'll realize that, okay, learning rate,
the next time when I'll start
retraining the network from the scratch,
then I'll increase it.
So yes, you can do that one.
Uh, so with the, with the experience, if you see that okay,
learning rate can be tuned,
you can do that. Yeah, definitely.
Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you. Mm-hmm.
That is, that is true. But again, I'll, I'll, I'll add on
to the same answer, which I have added earlier
with a hundred layers and millions of parameters, right?
I mean, it, it's very diff becomes really difficult
to even even understand that
what should be the learning rate, which I'll add, so
that it'll if improve the, uh, uh, loss
or it, it can, uh,
compensate on this small ingredient part what we are getting.
Yes. It's very difficult in reality.
It's very difficult. Yeah.
Yeah. Yes.
And you are, you then you may have to change learning net
for a hundred times, but then, I mean, if you have to do it
of all, all the things manually like this, you will,
it'll take a lot of time, lot of resources
and all those things, right?
Yeah. Yes. Is all the, the problems, correct?
Yeah. Yes. Thank you.
But, uh, uh, having said that, we'll see
that on the same line, we have some, some solutions
for this Spanish gradient problem, which do,
which does something with the learning rate like that.
Uh, and, but that we don't have to do it manually.
There is an algorithm which takes care of that.
Uh, the optimizers can kind
of software optimizes what we have.
That takes care of the same thing, what you have said. Yeah.
Mm-hmm. Yeah, sure, sir. Thank you. So, yes.
Any other query from anyone,
Sir? Um,
the activation function here, we, uh, we analyzed,
which, uh, has a gradient that is less than,
you know, less than one, right?
So, um, I think your time also has a gradient
that is less than some value survey.
I mean, it Only choice is only choice we have
is we use everywhere.
Yeah. So in, in most of the places, you will see
that in the al layers people use the
activation function, okay?
Okay. So at the output layer, there is a different choice
of activation functions, which you might be seeing, okay?
Because it depends on what kind of output I want to receive.
So, but in the hidden layer, people, uh, mostly prefer
to use the re reactivation function
because of this reason, what we have seen, right?
Uh, so that is, that is one, yeah,
that is one thing, correct.
So in the hidden layer, I mean,
most preferable choice is red.
Okay? Okay. Yeah.
And, um, uh, can you talk about the case
where the gradients explored?
Um, so it is another case gradient explored case I had
explained earlier where, uh,
we had seen this kind of issue.
Uh, if you can recall this slide, you see
what has happened here.
So the first time when we talked about this network,
I was explaining that, uh, calculating gradient
with respect to each of these.
But you see that what are the gradient value,
which we're getting 97.1 5, 2, 26 0.49, six and 14.
And when we have to multiply all these gradients,
all these values are very high, like 10.1, 0.2, one eight.
So corresponding radiant, what we are getting is very high
in the, so you see this, this value is very high,
and 9 42, 94, uh, 11.
And then see all these grades,
this is the grade gradient exploding is, okay.
So what is happening here is that, uh, my, this part,
this gradient part, as we go down in the network,
and if we have taken, uh, if it'll get multiply
with the bigger number again
and again, which is the case you have seen here,
because my inputs were like that or some somewhere.
Uh, so my, my value becomes very high.
No, here I did not, uh, brought that problem
and couldn't, did not introduce you.
Otherwise, it would've been a little complicated.
But this is the gradient exploding problem,
which we have already seen experienced.
And with the learning rate, again, we had controlled it,
but that was a manual effort learning rate.
I have taken 0.0004, uh,
with very small learning rate, right?
And, uh, I could take it
because these values were very, going, very high exploding.
If I would've not controlled it,
then I would've never converged it, uh,
or never, uh, reduced my loss.
But this is the problem of the exploding grad program. Yeah.
So, um, so the, the, I mean,
it all depends on the weight, uh, choice also, right?
Weight initializations, yes,
It depends on multiple factors.
Uh, we'll talk about the solutions,
but first of all, let us appreciate that, okay,
what is this vanishing gradient problem and
or excluding gradient problem?
And suppose it'll come and,
and definitely it'll come for the deeper networks.
Then how to hand, uh, how to handle
that part will see later then
how it'll impact on my learning process of the network.
So if that part is clear, then I'll explain you maybe, uh,
next, uh, after this demo, uh, we'll quickly see, okay,
what are the solutions for that?
So you rightly said that one
solution is weight initialization.
One solution is having this learning rate, how to control,
I mean, how to, when to keep less, when to keep, when
to increase, and so on.
Okay? And there are many other solutions also.
We'll see that one, the solutions of these
Four.
Thank you.
So, um, I have one question, sir. Yes, please.
So regarding this loss, if the loss is a non-zero, uh,
this learning, uh, like why does this, uh, uh,
learning stop in, uh, vanishing gradient?
Uh, loss is non? Yeah.
See, the ultimate idea is that this loss has come
because my weight somewhere was not in sliced properly.
Okay? So that is how we understood the loss,
why the loss is coming.
I have imagined for access equal
to one, Y is equal, equal to zero.
This is my actual input and actual target,
but I'm not getting it for some reason.
And the reason is only between this input and output.
And in between this input
and output, we have the parameters like these weights only.
Okay? So loss will be non, if suppose,
loss is non-zero, who is responsible?
So these parameters are, weights are responsible here.
So we slightly change these weights.
That is what is the next case?
That is the only possibility what we can do.
So if loss is non zero, you said that why,
when saying why we are getting gradient
as it very small, right?
Yeah, but the gradient is not depending.
Uh, a gradient is depending on,
because of this chain rule, uh,
the way we are calculating the gradient for the, uh, uh,
layers by layers, layers by layer.
Because this chain rule is a multiplication,
not multiplication between the gradients itself.
So if the loss is a small, say that this value is, uh,
this gradient is this much, then another, it'll multiply
with one more value, one more value.
So the, uh,
because the smaller value gets multiplied
with another smaller values, we result, we,
it is resulting in another very smaller values.
So that is how, that is how it is coming. Okay?
So this is, uh, this, uh,
because of the chain rule, uh, I think, uh,
that is the thing which you're asking.
Chain rule is the problem actually,
and loss is not the problem.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. And in one of, uh, slide you mentioned like, uh,
this, uh, shrink, uh, this, uh, what is that, uh, gradient,
uh, shrink, uh, this gradient shrink, uh, uh,
exponentially and it won't shrink, uh, linearly, right?
Like, what is why this?
Uh, so that's what I was, uh, uh, explaining here.
Yeah, that almost exponential decrease.
You can see in the gradient that it was here, almost,
if you see the 13 times,
it has decreased in just four layers when we go down from
the output to inputs, okay?
So if it, it'll go down, it'll, it'll, uh, if suppose,
see the gradient shrink, will, will,
will definitely be there.
But if it is not exponentially,
then there is no problem support slide gradient decreases
there in the next layer
or next layer, then that is, that's not a problem.
If the, the, the shrink is like
that, then that's the problem.
Yeah.
Thank you. Yes, yes.
Sorry, one question. Yeah.
So now the gradients are reducing, uh, having prop. Mm-hmm.
The layer layer. Can we bypass, uh, of the layers here,
Uh, bypass in the sense, uh, you let me know
what is the suppose gradient is here?
Something this layer decreasing further.
So in the back propagation, you don't want to calculate the,
uh, gradient here in this layer. This layer, yeah.
Yeah. Skip, Uh, that we cannot do. Why?
Because that's why I have explained to you earlier,
if you can remember the first slide on the last class
loss as a function of all trainable parameters.
So y hat is a function of parameter, V one, V two, V three,
and then Y hat, uh, V one, V two, V three depends on ZJ one,
uh, at H one and turns.
Z one, J one depends on W one one, W one, two B.
So if I'll expand this
equation, it looks something like that.
So my, this is the actual equation, these actual equations,
and one by one in the parcel derivative,
we calculate the loss first time, say that with respect
to one parameter, then next time with respect
to another parameter and so on.
So it's a nested function.
It's a nested function where you can't say that this,
I will skip completely.
Uh, I'll, I'll skip completely.
So, uh, I mean, that's not the gradient decent algorithm,
uh, says in the back propagation,
it treats each each parameters equally
and say that, okay, all the parameters are equally
responsible for the loss, what we are getting,
and hence we have to slightly modify
that one for the next titration.
No? Yeah, because I'll, the, uh,
manually I can do that one.
What you are trying to say that, okay, next time, if, uh,
I will set this one zero hard code, it,
although it is coming something,
but I, I can hard code it,
I will not change or whatever it is.
Or I can put a threshold that, okay,
if the gradient is going less than a particular value,
I will not change from the previous way.
All those things we can do. But imagine the bigger networks
where we are millions, trillions of neurons.
I mean, getting that inside of the network for which layer,
for what neurons it, it's almost impossible task.
So we have an algorithm and which works, which works
for equally for all the neurons
and all the weights in the same way.
That is the only possibility of, of,
uh, training such a big network.
Otherwise, it is very manual effort.
And, uh, yeah, those things we have.
Thanks. Yeah, bye.
Okay, so let us quickly see this.
This will not take much time now
because we have understood the
what is vanishing radiant problem.
I mean, it is the same thing.
Uh, what I have just explained with this, uh, help
of the slides.
Now I'm coding it.
So just wanted to explain so that, uh, you will, uh,
once again, you will see all these quote
and you will have some better understanding about these, uh,
uh, all these things, because quickly, now I'll show you.
I'm in the next class.
I'm going to switch, switch from, uh, um,
mean the PyTorch coding, which we are doing
so far from the scratch for most of the things, except
that back application.
Uh, we are going to build everything in the PyTorch modules.
We are going to use au modules, like
to build the neural network.
We'll use the module to do the, uh, gradient, uh,
anyway, we are using backward.
Then for application also,
we'll use the modules like the loss function.
We'll use the, uh, like some PyTorch module.
So then you will not be able to, uh,
view what is going inside.
So these codes will help you to, uh, like, uh, uh,
understand the black box later on.
Once we start using the built-in functions from the PyTorch,
uh, your code would be simplified,
but then you will not see much, much, uh, like, uh,
okay, what is happening inside.
So that clarity should come here itself.
Next level, when you go, you'll be able
to understand it clearly.
So you see this W one, W2, W three, W four are my weight.
So it's at tensors, zero dimension tensor.
That means these are all scaler
and requires grad is equal to true.
That means that I want the gradient with respect to W one,
then W2, W three, and all the parameter.
That is what I'm writing here.
Then I need my input output, which is again,
a scaler in this particular case.
One is the input, and zero is the output.
Now, sigmoid function will be the one which I'll be using it
inside all the neurons, all the hidden, uh, neuron in,
in fact, uh, in the output also, so
that I'm using from neural module, from the torch, okay?
NN module that we say
as NN neural network module in the torch.
Now, I'm not writing sigmoid function by my own.
So far I had written in the previous class
and all, you must have seen those codes,
but now I'm not writing it anymore.
I'm using this NNNN module.
I'll explain about the NN module in the next class
in more detail.
So, but it is just a sigmoid implementation. Nothing else.
Now, these are all the empty list,
because I'm going to use them for plotting and all that.
How my loss is changing across their box,
how my gradient is changing
for W one across their box, right?
Uh, all those things, uh, updated weights are changing
means these, these four are not required
because anyway, we are setting the gradient to zero
after every apoc,
but then you can always store it updated W one, okay?
Yeah, this is very much important
how the weight values are changing in first OC and second OC
and third OC that for that one,
these are all the empty list.
We utilize learning rate value, 0.01, OC
set here, 50.
Now here, uh, it's a forward pass.
Easy to understand. First of all, we do W one, two x, uh,
then pass it through the sigma.
We get get at E one. Now, E one gets multiplied with the W2.
Pass it through sigmoid.
We get a two W three, a two sigmoid, a three,
and finally a three into W four.
Sigmoid. Yha, okay? Same thing. Exactly. Same thing.
What we have done here, I'm now explaining here, okay,
so this is the same forward pass, which we had done here.
So here, okay, so I guess this is clear.
Then once we have this Y hat, we calculate the loss.
Loss is Y hat minus y square,
and one by two, as I explained,
we have taken in the equation.
So loss value we get here, whatever loss value I'm getting,
extract that loss
and upend that loss in the loss history, loss history list,
which was the empty list.
So in every och, we'll get some loss history, right?
And we are going to upend that in the loss history
because later on I'll utilize this one to plot my loss,
how it's changing, not changing, or whatever it is.
So this completes my forward pass.
This whole completes my forward pass.
Now we have a backward pass.
So for backward pass, I'm not writing the gradient
calculation code.
Uh, but we had done it earlier. Just to simplify.
We used backward module from the PyTorch.
Now, this will do gradient calculation with respect
to all the parameters.
Wherever I have put require, grad is equal two, two.
So W one, W2, W three, W four, it'll calculate the gradient.
X, Y it'll not calculate
because it, it doesn't have the required grad is equal two.
True. Okay?
So one second.
See, X looks something like that.
See, but if I print my
W one, it says that this is the value of W one
and it required grad.
So that information, clearly we are saying that the x,
it is not required that grad, but for W one, it's required.
Okay? So that we have made, made sure that now, uh,
okay, a few more things.
What we can do, just to see that,
how it'll do the back propagation,
you can print this A one eight to, uh, okay,
this is not run so far.
Let me run this. Okay, done.
So now, if I print this, now this A one, if you see that,
because it is going to calculate the partial derivative
of loss with respect to a one also,
which is nothing but the sigmoid.
So it'll calculate the partial derivative
of sigmoid here, remember?
So, and that is, uh, that is how the back propagation.
So here, when it'll calculate with respect to a one,
it knows that it has to calculate the partial derivative
of sigmoid because the backward operation,
which was performed on the, uh,
back operation performed on the, uh, performed
to get this A one was sigmoid.
So it'll calculate here the gradient of sig mite.
Similarly, similarly, you can also see that, okay,
what was the, uh, what is this Z one?
Um, uh, all, all those values, uh,
I guess you can easily, okay?
One is not defined here, right? So that one, uh, one second.
So W one oh, Z one is not one.
That one, we have not stored this, this particular.
Otherwise, that one also would've to say
that backward operation is backward operation is this,
uh, uh, multiplication?
Okay? Uh, we could have done this, but we have not done.
Uh, so, uh, if you wanted to see that, also suppose just,
just for, for that one.
So whatever you will do,
I will just simply copy this line here, okay?
This will be same. Now this will my Z one.
This is my Z one where I only calculate the
double one into X, and here I pass my chat one.
That's all. This is what it'll do, okay?
Then if you will see the Z one value, it is weighted value.
W one, two x and then backward operation
is multiplication, isn't it?
You see, this backward operation is W one two x.
So once it'll start doing the partial of Z one with respect
to W one, with respect to W one, also, it'll understand why,
because W one I said that requires to true,
but for XI said that it is false.
So once it'll end up with this equation
and find, okay, partial derivative, it'll calculate
with W one, it'll not calculate with respect to X.
That is how this, this backward operation is working, okay?
It has all the computational graph that
how this value was computed,
what was the previous operation,
but that value it stores, okay?
That is how this backward propagation works.
Now, that is all, once you have this backward, uh, computed,
then then you will update your, uh, uh,
here the weight update will happen.
That W one is equal two W one minus learning
rate into the gradient.
Then W2 and so on.
And then all these values, I'm just storing, uh,
just storing to, uh, to plot that here.
The last one is I'm just detaching my all the W one value
and initializing it with the zero.
So that next epoch, when it'll start that time,
it'll not take the previous, uh, uh, double, uh, uh, what is
that gradient value.
So that's all. So once this is done, then maybe this is,
this is how the gradients are coming across the layer,
and this, this particular cell will show you
some, some plots.
Now, if you see the plots, what will happen? 0.2.
Uh, my loss start with somewhere more than 1, 6 2,
end up at 1 5, 4.
See, the loss is decreasing a slightly
because it's very simplest network.
It was, it was slightly decreasing.
If you see here that, uh, uh, how,
how the way, the way this, uh, what is this EPOCH gradient?
Gradient gradient was also slightly changing
at the, at the fourth layer.
This is the fourth layer gradient, W four. Okay?
Now this is the third layer,
and if you observe the gradient of W2
and W one, this is almost flat.
At least you see some variations in blue and orange,
but there is hardly any variations in this, uh, green
and uh, green and red line, right?
That means that the early layers of gradient with respect
to W one, W2 is almost not changing, okay?
It's almost zero. Similarly, you see that the weight update,
because gradients are not changing here.
Weight update also
for the early layers are almost negligible,
but there is slight weight update in for the, uh,
W four and W three.
Now, this is the chain. So you can do, I mean,
here the network is very simplest, so it wasn't,
it is not showing you very significant thing.
But going further, when we use the bigger network,
which I plan to use it for, which I plan
to show you from next class, you will see the lot of, uh,
uh, large variations.
Large variations in that one, okay?
And, uh, yeah, this is the demonstration
of the exactly same thing, what we have seen you do,
the practice change, some parameters understand internally
what is happening, okay?
And so because these are all the foundations which you
should be having, going further,
you may see most of the things black box.
Okay? So having the good clarity
of all these concepts are very important.
I'll stop here. In the next class,
we'll see all these things, how
to handle the vanishing gradient problem.
Uh, some of you mentioned, I, uh,
that relu I can use instead of sigmoid,
I can use the better weight initialization.
There's something called B normalization,
something called skip connections.
Okay? All these things we'll see.
And uh, we'll see these with the help of the, uh, modules
as well as some data, little bigger data set, so
that you will be seeing, okay, by adding
or deleting these, these, uh, these,
how it'll impact on the grad gradient,
whether the gradient is brandished
or being improved,
all those things we are going to see next.
Okay? So solutions we'll see in the next class, next class,
you'll also write the quiz.
So first you'll write the quiz maybe for 30 minutes,
and, uh, then time, whatever time we left with, we'll try
to cover some of the topics.
Okay? So it'll obviously go
for the next to next class as well.
Now, I'll, I'll stop here. You can
ask me some question before we,
Uh, yes, actually regarding quiz in next class.
Mm-hmm. It has said
that next week we'll be having an offline event in college.
So would there be any classes?
So quiz connected next week, this coming Saturday.
I mean, this is the Saturday.
Next Saturday, you're saying that?
Yes, sir. Yes sir. Oh, so some
of you will be here in the college by then, right?
Yes, sir. Uh, then what we'll do is, uh, we'll,
we'll have the class, let us not, uh, uh,
let us not cancel the class,
but, uh, I will see that if I can do it in the hybrid mode
so that uh, others who are not coming can join online
and who are coming, they can experience the class also.
I mean, that's just an option.
Anyway, you'll be here, we can decide what we can do,
but I believe that would be better
so that we are coming here.
Let us have one class offline. Also, it means hybrid also.
Okay, sir? Yeah.
Or you are, you are coming only for uh, uh, just
to see the in and on.
That is different thing there.
Well, anything is, so we don't know
The, we, we don't have the agenda.
Also, what is the, what is been planned?
Yeah. I'll tell you the main agenda
of these immerson program is that once you come
to the campus, you get to see who is the professors,
which you have been interacting online,
and, uh, get little more discussions on your projects part.
If there is any class, which is, if it is not scheduled,
the class will not have a, because it is scheduled on
that day, let us have one class also, uh, then, so that,
that will help you for your later part of the visualizations
where again, you will not be coming here,
but then you can always imagine this is how it was, right?
So main agenda is to interact
with the professors clarity on the, on the topics projects.
Now, these are the main agenda. Yeah.
Get to know the camp campus, see that what is there,
and all get the feeling. So,
So this is, So it's only on Saturday, Sunday.
There's nothing we can return back on Sunday also. Right? So
I, I, I believe that schedule even, I don't know as
of now, maybe Will will be the right person.
He, he will share, share with you. Okay. Uh, before time.
So even, I don't know the exact, uh, what are the plans?
I don't know about that.
Sure. Thank you. Yeah,
We'll see that. No
Problem. Okay.
Alright. So I think we can stop here then we'll
meet on Monday.
Seven, five. Okay? Yeah, sure, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. When is the quiz, sir?
Thank you, sir. Excuse me, sir, when is the quiz?
Next class? Next class,
which is Monday
until now. Uh, whatever
Syllabus will be everything. Whatever we have covered
Today.
Thank you, sir. Yeah, thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir. Thank you, sir.